buenos días
el 43% de peruanos estamos dispuestos a
iniciar un negocio en los próximos tres
años
somos el quinto país más emprendedor del
mundo
pero el 30% tenemos miedo a fracasar
el primer trimestre de este año en la
ciudad se registraron 66 mil empresas y
se cerraron un poquito más de la mitad
37 mil
esta es mi casa era mi casa
viví prácticamente desde que nací hasta
los 6 años
girón monitor huáscar 370 rímac segundo
piso ahí arriba
vivía con mis papis y mis hermanitos y a
los 6 años decidí emprender teníamos una
vecina la señora luz mami te acuerdas
estaba después del chifa por aquí vivía
en una quinta ella vendía unos ricos y
deliciosos choux de fruta así que casi
todos los días iba a comprar le pedía
plata a mi mami mami los chips mami la
plata
mi mamá me los lava feliz hasta que un
día me dijo basta
todos los días
y obviamente tenía razón y decidí que yo
también podía hacer los chips
se sumó la lom y hermano mayor nos
llevamos un año y meses así que estamos
somos contemporáneos mi mamá nos llevó
al mercado nos enseñó a comprar la fruta
compramos las bolsitas el embudo la
licuadora nos enseñó a preparar todo
hicimos letrerito 30 céntimos el chip de
fruta lo colocamos
y nadie venía
pero estaba mamá mamá nos compraban para
nuestros amiguitos para nosotros para
las abuelas para los tíos creo que le he
comprado cualquier persona que pasaba
con tal de ayudarnos y así ese fue
nuestro primer emprendimiento y con la
lo
hasta ahora no paramos
es el halo el que está ahí
es contador no aparece de verdad es muy
creativo
es de mi papá y mi mami aquí estamos en
el mercado ellos
son lo máximo
son emprendedores desde muy pequeñitos
son las cabezas o los hermanos mayores
su familia así que decidieron emprender
por necesidad desde muy pequeñitos así
que el emprendimiento lo llevamos en la
sangre mis abuelos también sorprende
dores mis abuelos paternos vienen de
huancayo y mis abuelos paternos de
obrajillo de kart a conocer
pusieron sus negocios comenzaron en lima
y mis papas siguieron así que nosotros
los tres hermanos también los
acompañamos ellos fundaron el 79 el
restaurante de pescados y mariscos el
piano nuestra primera escuela mi escuela
ahí nos enseñaron a comprar aire al
terminal pesquero al 3 de febrero a la
parada cuidamos carros en el local
limpiamos mariscos hasta que el arroz
intoxicó con ese le hizo el ojo así
pero era un ambiente para nosotros de
juego y ver a mis papás despertarse cada
mañana sonriendo y muy temprano y gran
terminar pesqueros se tiene que ir
temprano y con la emoción que iba yo
quería ser como ellos claro que quería
ser como ellos
han sido siempre mi ejemplo
aquí estoy yo cuando presente disfruta
la primera vez que presente disfruta
ante un jurado en la universidad
mis papás siempre creyeron y creen que
la educación nos hará diferentes ellos
no pudieron terminar sus estudios
superiores pero creyeron que nosotros en
sus hijos si la podíamos lograr y se
sacrificaron y se sacaron el lunch y se
despertaron por 35 años muy temprano en
la mañana para comprar pescado para el
restaurante
y así tuvimos la suerte mi hermano mayor
estudió contabilidad y estudió
administración y el menor derecho parece
un equipo bien armadito no falta siempre
le digo a mi papá faltaron más hijos
pero si seguimos seguimos su ejemplo la
primera vez que si pensamos en disfruta
con lalo fue cuando estábamos en cuarto
ciclo de la universidad ahí dijimos ok
papá nos da a papá y mamá nos dan
el privilegio de estudiar o estar en las
aulas pero no tenemos otros ingresos y
con la lo decidimos poner un restaurante
pero disfruta una juguería el primer
concepto de disfruta
teníamos un espacio que papá y mamá nos
habían dado y fuimos a sacar la licencia
municipal esto sin antes de preguntarle
mi abuela a mi abuela mi mamita daría
manejo una juguería durante 52 años
imagínense la reina de las frutas o de
los jugos fuimos a preguntarle y nos
dijo solo nos dijo que nos iba a ir
genial que vayan adelante súper
emprendedor ella también pero dijo solo
una cosita sean formales mi abuela tenía
una juguería un puesto ambulante y
siempre nos decía que él ha molestado
así que por favor que no los molesten
que saquen su negocio es horrible que
estén de informales por favor sacan su
licencia y fue la primera el primer
fracaso no nos dieron la licencia
pedimos cita con el alcalde dos meses
después nos dieron cita con el alcalde
le presentamos el proyecto que queríamos
una juguería que no sé cuál teníamos
experiencia que somos jóvenes
emprendedores que queremos abrir
adelante el alcalde nos dijo que bien
que más pero no les doy la licencia
y así fue no nos dieron la licencia y
comenzamos a pensar y ahora qué hacemos
bueno nos quedaba recolocarnos trabajar
para conseguir más dinero así que
conseguimos prácticas preprofesionales y
ahí comenzamos pero la idea daba vueltas
y vueltas y con lalo nos juntábamos y
dad y decíamos oye qué están haciendo
las juguerías en el mundo como son las
juguerías acá lo primero que nos dimos
es que si los pero no somos muy muy muy
jugados tomamos jugó en la mañana hubo
un buen almuerzo y jugó en la noche así
que había una oportunidad y le dimos
todo nuestro conocimiento profesional a
armar ese proyecto disfruta ahí fue
cuando lo presenté fue un proyecto
innovador porque le damos todo un giro
al comercio de juderías que era conocido
como un negocio menor de mercado y
muchas veces ambulante
comenzamos con con el proyecto lo
presentamos ante un jurado de la
universidad
muchos profesores no creían que podíamos
hacer una juguería y tanta inversión en
una juguería pero lo presentamos fuimos
el proyecto que obtuvo en la mejor nota
de la promoción ese año
este disfruta el primero disfruta
lindo
comenzamos también fue muy muy muy
difícil igual se repitió la historia no
nos dieron la licencia pero esta vez no
por problemas municipales sino que la
junta de vecinos se opuso que esto va a
ser una juguería eso parece una
discoteca un restaurante fue nuestra
segunda gran exposición de disfrutar ya
no en tanto ante un jurado académico
universitario sino ante los vecinos a
decirle que si una juguería puede tener
este impacto puede tener esta imagen y
puede ser grande así que así comenzamos
abrimos un 29 de mayo del 2007 mi
cumpleaños
fue medio kármico pero ahí los
lo abrimos tuvimos una serie serie de
dificultades para abrir pero lo logramos
después asistimos a una feria a una
feria pequeña importante donde vendía
estaba un espacio de comidas había un
espacio de venta de ropa otro de
diversión y no fue súper bien inclusive
mejor que nuestro local así que
decidimos que se parece a esto cuál es
este formato que nos va tan bien vivimos
los centros comerciales comenzamos a
tocar todos los centros comerciales de
lima nadie creía en nuestro proyecto
nadie
hasta que uno nos abrió un espacio pero
no en lima en chiclayo
y con la lo como somos medios loquitos
nos fuimos papá y mamá nos dijeron con
cuidado
no los escuchamos
este fue el segundo local que abrimos en
chiclayo no era un centro comercial
propiamente dicho los que sabemos ahora
de retail moderno era un power center no
existían anclas no había espacio muy
definido de tiendas
de retail menor es por lo tanto a los
días con lalo nos dimos cuenta que no
iba a funcionar no sabíamos habíamos
invertido todo el poquito dinero que
habíamos conseguido en el rastrillo y en
nuestro primer emprendimiento y chiclayo
no iba a funcionar
que decidimos seguir
no medimos las consecuencias nos hicimos
un préstamo a un prestamista ya se
imaginarán los intereses
en medio de un año cerramos pero en este
transcurso se acercó una persona y nos
dijo tenemos un centro comercial y vamos
a abrir 10 más en el perú el mismo
gerente general y me encanta tu proyecto
les va muy bien y yo quiero apostar por
ustedes entonces como teníamos los
recursos invertidos en chiclayo abrimos
a dos cuadras en un centro comercial que
sí tenía anclas todo el espacio de
infraestructura que conocíamos y así fue
este fue mi nuestro tercer nuestro
primer módulo en realidad porque los
otros eran tipo más como locales nuestro
primer módulo en en chiclayo
aquí estuvimos nos fue súper bien
dijimos este es el formato hay que
replicar lo seguimos creciendo y
comenzamos a crecer sin parar
abrimos en julián acá en huancayo en
trujillo en piura como 5 más en lima
nos fuimos arequipa cusco y así pasaron
casi 8 años donde llegamos a tener 30
locales
aparentemente disfruta era todo un éxito
no lo era
cometimos una serie de errores una serie
de errores 1 creer que lo podíamos hacer
todos nosotros yo
que podíamos seguir y sobre todo que
podíamos seguir con estos locales que no
funcionaban que uno compensado al otro
nos llevamos entrampando y entrampando y
ahorcando y ahorcando
el 2016
perdimos todas casi todas nuestras
ubicaciones
le había fallado a las personas que más
amaba
a mis papás
todo su esfuerzo
sus amanecidas
toda su inversión en tiempo pero sobre
todo en amor
le falla a mi esposo
a mi hija
tenía semanas de embarazo cuando
decidimos esto estuve internada una
semana en la clínica recién salí cuando
deje de sangrar
estaba derrumbando no sólo disfruta sino
me estaba derrumbando yo hoy estaba
derrumbando a las personas que más
quería le falte a mis colaboradores le
falla a mis proveedores
le estaba fallando todo mi equipo y se
estaba derrumbando mis sueños
me sentía sola
perdidas
hipotecamos mi casa la perdí
nadie sabía nada no quería contar nada
pero me decidí levantar es su
responsabilidad su cena y tienes que
levantarte porque eso lo viste en casa
porque lo viste con tus abuelos lo
vistes con tus papás lo ves en tu esposo
lo ves en tu hija que está luchando por
su vida
lo primero es aceptar es aceptar que
fallamos es aceptar que no está
emprendimiento nuestro proyecto fracaso
los segundos apoyarnos en las personas
que más amamos que más queremos porque
el tema emocional nos derrumba y nos
deja en el suelo es lo más difícil
el tercero es el apoyo profesional
buscar a gente que sepa de tu tema que
sepa de lo que estás hablando que te
ayude a salir de esto diariamente
y guardo como esfuerzo el horror
tal
a detalle y duele duele saber cada error
que tuviste y cada error que pasaste
duele saber el daño ves tus heridas que
ya sanaron pero duele volver a repasar
las volver a recordar ese episodio
y el último a seguir
y seguir adelante
porque seguir
porque son las empresas las que fracasan
no las personas
jamás tus sueños
gracias
[Aplausos]